holy cow Wow live applause on YouTube
has this ever happened before that is
incredible that is amazing I am Dave
Rubin this is the Rubin report we are at
YouTube space la and we are in the midst
of the greatest gay time ever is this
has it ever been better for the gays
this is it okay
all right you guys aren't that impressed
it started you clapped a little and then
you kind of brought everybody along that
was good okay very good we got a great
show for you guys we're gonna be talking
about some LGBT issues I've got some
great choice gays with me and you know
part of what YouTube is doing right now
on their spotlight channel they're doing
they're proud to love campaign and this
is where they're showing people talking
about who they love why they love what
they love and I put up a video with my
grandma and let's take a look you can't
be sure of anything yeah you should be
you should be yeah that's the most
important things would be a conquest
yeah but it'd be good nice to people
yeah and a few years ago I told you that
I was gay but people say that it's a
generational
people the older people don't like you
younger people do but yeah what do you
think you forgot I mean I told you I
told you that a diner took you out for
lunch and I well I guess not
known it but I never think about it it
doesn't matter to me yeah how many
people are speakers yeah you can speak
peanuts a good person that's it that's
all the class yeah good way to start the
show okay so let's get right to we got
some great panelists first up we've got
to the gay pimp himself Johnny McGovern
next up we have YouTube sensation Miss
Hannah Hart from the real l word we have
whitney mixter
goodbye that has given me a
million-dollar smile from AMC showgirl
Alec mapa and a second youtube sensation
because it's all about the subscribers
people bree essrig
alright guys so we got a lot of gay
stuff to talk about first off are you
guys all comfortable sitting here gay
people is like a zoo like they're
watching us we got in a zoo I thought
you were gonna ask are you comfortable
being gay yeah yeah now that you mention
it yeah no I thought you were gonna ask
are you comfortable sitting this close
to gay people yeah because I'm not as a
lesbian is that weird for you to see
them I'm very proximate II yeah I would
say there's a testosterone over a little
bit I'm not sure I think that's coming
for me DOMA the big news it has happened
it is over we will be able to be equal
we'll start wearing pleated pants and be
boring that's all we've ever wanted okay
it's great now I believe that two of our
panelists here are actually married yeah
thank you
not to each other to each other but you
know the DOMA thing that the first thing
I thought of because I'm married and we
have a we have an eight-year-old son and
we came back from an international trip
one time and we were checking in through
customs you know you come in and you
fill out the forms and the head of
household fills out one form right so we
went up to the customs counter as a
family this was maybe two years ago and
they said what's this with us about I
said we're a family it says you're
married he says yeah we're married well
we don't recognize that here and my son
was like six years old at the time and
he came up to the counter he goes who's
this he goes it's our son said you
adopted him he goes yes and then he
started backpedaling for being such a
douche like all about me it's it's the
law we don't recognize his here I mean
like totally mortified that he had been
rude to two parents in front of their
own kid and now the minute DOMA passed
that was one of the things that's going
to change immediately
is that we're gonna be recognized as a
family we won't be kind of scrutinized
in the same way before we'll be able to
go through customs like everybody else
yeah and that seems like a kind of a
trivial thing but it did matter
well they feel like the spotlight was on
us like oh you're different
oh you're different and and less than in
this circumstance yeah and that's the
thing I mean all that any of us want is
you know we're gay we want the same
things but the only difference is we're
gay so we want nicer things now lately
you also married I think you got married
you got married in that brief window
when property wasn't didn't happen yet
and there was a minor moment oh no no I
did not know and this is the thing I
actually got legally married in
Connecticut then I had a big wedding in
California so now I guess I need to get
remarried to my wife for a third time
again in California I think there should
start like this new kind of like tally
system a competition of how many times a
gay person can get married and how many
say it says no but it's registered each
time you would totally cash it oh my god
I know I broke it out yesterday I broke
out my 1-year frozen wedding cake did
not wait for it to thaw and just went
for it hard yeah in honor of DOMA I was
like pouring some of my 40 out sorry
Johnny
you are up I believe you're single so
how does DOMA affect the modern single
gave oh thank you we'll look Dave I'm
not married yet but when the time comes
for the me to have my coming to America
style buddy with elephants poking ball
queens on a wreath of Franklin coming
out from a reversible aisle that
extravaganza will be federally
recognized
certainly worthy of around Oh boys it
Hannah what about you are you are you
excited you have any big plans of coming
Wow lucky ladies we need to know about
yeah no I you know for the first time in
a while I am actually seeing someone and
it's gone pretty great but you know
we'll see how it is I live a very public
life so I'm trying to keep things really
slow and casual but then dolma passes
gotta get married quick okay how many
text messages did you guys all get
yesterday already getting married agree
did you get any believe it or not it got
none no no Brad you are bisexual so how
do you feel about what happened
yesterday because you kind of could have
got married before anybody Hey yeah I
mean I have all the options open to me
that's great but I mean my own personal
thoughts on marriage aside I hate being
told what to do so the fact that I'm
allowed to do whatever I want now is
awesome yeah yeah does it seem crazy to
you guys that these nine stodgy people
in robes kind of astounded every day
about how much anybody gives a [ __ ]
exactly yeah because if they knew what
my life was like what my gay marriage
looked like it would be if you tuned in
to our house if there was like a cam you
would see my husband and I folding
laundry while our kids asleep after 8:30
watching So You Think You Can Dance and
that's the big Okubo god that's what
people there is the whole gather gay sex
thing but other than that but phenomenal
it's it astounds me that we've taken it
this far but the great thing about DOMA
was and and the prop 8 case was they
they presented in a lawyerly way and
they really ask people what harm is
being done to you what harm will come to
you from these marriages and they were
they were supposed to have six witnesses
for dropped out two showed up and
none of them could state a case of a way
that they would be harmed in a real
concrete way yeah so if it takes that
discussion it takes the gravity of that
discussion to kind of prove that nothing
bad is going to happen then that's what
it's gonna take but there's still people
yakking about it today I think it's a
lot about I recently just went on a tour
around America and I think that we are
very fortunate to live in the bubbles
that we do you know I've always lived in
California or I've lived in New York and
going around the states you really can
see that it's not it's not like how it
is here so it seems so strange to us
that people you know give any shits
about what we do with our lives but when
you get out there it's just a real sense
of like other nests it's a difference
and it makes people uncomfortable makes
them scared because it it what it does
is it compromises everything that they
believe to be the same and to be right
yeah which is you know so where then do
we put religion in this whole thing
because that seems to be the last part
of it that people are fighting with us
right where do you think we put know
what that argument is that argument even
valid public square no I don't think you
should put that with anything like my
own personal God likes me no matter what
you are personal God is gonna like you
no matter I mean it doesn't matter I
know we're not a theocracy
that's Afghanistan that's Iran if you
want a state that's run by the church
that's what you got oh yeah I'd rather a
state run by a bunch of people listening
to us
absolutely uh you know it's unfortunate
because as a youtuber you get feedback
in your comments a lot and every time
you know something gay gets like brought
up people say people do sometimes get
uncomfortable about their religions and
you know I you know I have my personal
beliefs in like God and it doesn't
nothing is jeopardized you know and I
feel that people think you're
automatically by being a happy gay
person you're automatically attacking
their beliefs fundamentally but the
truth is you're not you know if you're
openly attacking them then yes yeah I'm
gay Jesus definitely approves of gay
marriage a Jesus moment for us all that
was a game
is gonna officiate your wedding day
Jesus is Arnie that's don't like him you
know
he's not gonna go once he's gonna go
he's gonna be in charge he has to be me
to read the right